every day more than 2 billion people use
the social media app called Tick Tock
many of them are young people under the
age of 24. if you had kids you probably
know already how Tick Tock Works Tick
Tock lets users upload short videos
usually they're under 30 seconds
what's interesting is that the content
of these videos varies a lot depending
upon what country you're in if you're in
China where Tick Tock is headquartered
you tend to get more educational content
but if you live in this country you get
an awful lot of Filth and propaganda
tailored for kids we're not guessing
about this we ran an experiment to prove
it last summer watch
The Tick Tock that Chinese residents
children in China get to see is very
different from the one your kids are
looking at here
now in China where Tick Tock is known
under a different name videos like these
are very common watch
[Music]
you know what American Kids your kids
are watching on Tick Tock stuff like
this
happy birthday
[Music]
well that's kind of weird can you see
what's going on here well China does
they run Tick Tock and China knows if
you want a productive society that
extends Beyonce next week you teach your
kids about hard work and creativity and
personal responsibility respect for
authority but if you want to destroy a
society you funnel a ton of garbage to
kids about gender ideology and twerking
as the accountant lives of tick tock has
documented extensively that's exactly
what Tick Tock is doing here there's a
whole genre of videos of teachers
boasting about
indoctrinating kids
I have had multiple students come out to
be not just with their sexuality but
also with their gender identity it's one
of the reasons I think it's so important
to be out and loud and proud I teach my
elementary school students about gender
identity some people are girls some are
boys some are both some are neither I
might tell this kid we do have a flag in
the class that you can
Pledge Your Allegiance to and he like
looks around he goes oh that one
so it goes without saying that net net
as they say tick tock is not a positive
influence on American society and right
now in response to criticism of tick
tock China's government and the company
itself are doing the same thing they did
when they responded to allegations of a
lab leak in Wuhan they're saying anyone
who raises questions is a racist and
they're doing that everywhere across the
media and they can because a lot of the
news that you consume is paid for by
tick tock
Politico a completely completely
ideologically corrupt organization on
Northern Virginia has a so-called
Playbook that is sponsored by Tick Tock
every other week
CNN meanwhile just put his Tech reporter
on the air to inform you that
criticizing Tick-Tock opens up Chinese
Americans to quote hate and violence
if you criticize Tick-Tock you're
killing Asian people
so confronted with all this you might
support efforts in the Congress right
now to ban Tick-Tock all together and a
lot of people do
not just on the right but also on the
left which is kind of interesting this
is one of those weird moments where
there's or appears to be some kind of
bipartisan consensus and that alone
might want to make you pause for a
second if everyone in power is saying
the same thing is it really a good idea
let's take a closer look and again this
is not a defensive Tick Tock merely an
acknowledgment of what's actually
happening in Washington right now so one
of the bills that would ban Tick Tock is
being pushed as we said by senators in
both parties it's called the restrict
Act Mark Warner of Virginia and John
thune of South Dakota Democrat and
Republican introduces legislation now
the bill is ostensibly a protecting
American National Security and ending
quote foreign adversaries from
interfering in our elections through
apps like Tick Tock because of course
election interference by Twitter and
Facebook is no problem at all but
election interference from Tick Tock is
totally unacceptable okay
but in reality and you should know this
if you're opposed to tick tock as we are
this bill isn't really about banning
Tick Tock it's never about what they say
it is instead this bill would give
enormous and terrifying new powers to
the federal government
to punish American citizens and regulate
how they communicate with one another
for example the bill would regulate
quote certain transactions between
persons in the United States and foreign
adversaries now what's a foreign
adversary and who gets to decide oh well
the Secretary of Commerce and the
department and the dni
not the Congress get to decide what
foreign adversaries are well that ought
to trip a switch in your brain and then
the transactions with foreign
adversaries would include quote any
acquisition importation transfer
installation dealing in or use of any
information and Communications
technology product or service including
ongoing activities such as mandated
Services data transmission software
updates repairs or the provision of data
hosting Services well that's pretty
Broad
under this bill if you engage in any of
that with the so-called foreign
adversary as determined by in this case
the byte Administration that would allow
the Secretary of Commerce Gina raimondo
and the Director of National
Intelligence April Haynes
to decide whether you're acting in the
quote interest of a foreign adversary
again that's another term that the
Executive Branch the Secretary of
Commerce gets to Define without the
interference of Congress
so if the bite Administration decides
that you're doing this then the
Secretary of Commerce can then enforce
quote any mitigation measure to address
any risk arising from any covered
transaction with any person or with
respect to any property subject to the
jurisdiction of the United States
these covered transactions can involve
quote current Pastor potential future
transactions
and the mitigation member measures
include but are not limited to throwing
American citizens in prison for 20 years
think about that for a minute so you
would be allowing the Executive Branch
the bid Administration to regulate
speech on the internet and if you are
somehow involved with the quote foreign
adversary or let's say you oppose the
war against Russia
you go to prison for 20 years
so this isn't about
Banning Tick Tock this is about
introducing flat out totalitarianism
into our system
now just because Tick Tock is so
unappealing because it's a creepy low IQ
Chinese plot designed to make your kids
trans and it is
that does not mean that the people
trying to ban Tick Tock have your
interests in mind oh it definitely
doesn't or Americas keep in mind these
are exactly the same people who drained
our strategic petroleum reserve and in
fact promote China at every turn now
they're telling you they're against
China they're not
this is not an effort to push back
against China it's part of a strategy to
make America much more like China
with the government in charge of what
you read and see and with terrifying
punitive Powers at their fingertips
now we've seen this before from the
National Security State again and again
confronted with the foreign adversary
for example after 9 11 the federal
government uses the opportunity to
expand their police Powers over the
American population
and they do it under false pretexts and
they do it quickly
by whipping people into a panic usually
that's rooted in some truth Tick Tock is
bad sure
Al Qaeda was terrible of course
but these measures are not aimed at
stopping the foreign threat they're
aimed at controlling the American
population they rush it through
and they do it
so quickly that no one ever explains how
exactly this is preserve American
National Security now according to Sandy
Cortez we really quote her
Congress has not even briefed on any of
this watch
usually when the United States is
proposing a very major move that has
something to do with significant risk to
National Security one of the first
things that happens is that Congress
receives a classified briefing and I can
tell you that Congress has not received
a classified briefing around the
allegations of National Security risks
regarding Tick Tock so why would we be
proposing a ban regarding such a
significant issue without being clued in
on this at all it just doesn't feel
right
okay so again in case you think we've
gone crazy and we're defending Sandy
Cortez we should point out that she is a
a tool of the National Security State
she's out promoting a war against Russia
and anyone who asks questions is an ally
of Putin
and she's probably acting for motives
that we find well abhorrent
but the question that she raises is real
and we want to be honest enough to say
that this may be one of those times when
they're common in Washington where the
solution has nothing to do with the
problem and in fact degrades our free
country and makes it something
unrecognizable
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight